mm go in red when I bareback welcome
back to some more The Walking Dead we
have two left shell and wet I promise I
do shell I don't even know if I'm
pronouncing that ranked but yeah look at
that each sign I feel like there should
be a D and an H at the end of it in the
beginning or now whatever I'm not I
don't know what to talk about so that's
how huh I like a boots what a man can
appreciate good weight good shoes BAM
Bing
beautiful play
reminds me of when I was ill all by
riding naked in the films Michelle your
sister's getting pretty good huh Becca
had a good teacher stuff thank you for
doing that
she needs something to focus on besides
you know is that meeting else yeah
growing up in a world like this what do
you think that does to a kid oh they did
to them how to play guitar
I'm trying to protect her from it as
much as possible things are stable here
for now I wanted to grow up with this
not what's outside these walls Beck is a
good kid he's a [ __ ] times she's gonna
go through that but if we can keep her
from experiencing some of the [ __ ] I've
seen thanks Stephanie Rana
wouldn't this attract Sammy's this is
really a good idea Pekka that was great
thanks thanks this you think we can do
something like this every week yeah that
sounds like a great idea
yeah why not you can all get in on it
like some kind of weekly talent show
that was amazing Becca we could all use
a little more music in our lives
did I ever tell you that I used to play
in a band yes Roman you've told us she
doesn't want to hear about it again all
right all right in that case let's get
back to work I recognize his voice oh
and thanks to Boyd's hard work on the
vegetable garden we're having fresh soup
tonight yay
okay let's get to it you want to help me
in she'll do the supply inspection cool
Dana barbecue check the flashlights
that's it I'll look over the guns ignore
that I'm sick
okay but be careful but be careful
people's lives depend on those we can't
have him screwing up because we got lazy
she'll when you get a sec meet me out
back help me feed the watchdogs
sure thing watchdogs goddess okay let's
look at the guns how we doing on ammo
better than we thought we haven't had to
use these for a while
well that's good what did Roman want I
don't know yet are you gonna find out
yeah in a sec I feel like things will go
to [ __ ] really quick here you guys need
help now we got this right Becca you go
ahead and help Roman out back jeez fine
what about this photo the diner looked
pretty nice back then that's because
they used to pay people to clean it also
not as many dead visitors back then ah
good one I don't get what she's talking
about okay where the hell is he there we
go wonderful what is this doing we
should do an inspection on these make
sure they all work we should safety
first right press we need to go over
here maybe we should check here just for
fun see what's up we got some smells
good doesn't look good
how can you cook for so many people
every single day it's gotta be so hard
to get food and she's left no I'm just
saying alright let's check on the guard
dogs or whatever Oh starting to thin out
in here thank God we have a garden now
thank God indeed what oh you scared me I
least in watch dogs yes he knows it's
feeding time
wait they feed them
what the [ __ ] got an animal Roman well
it's not human either not anymore you
know sister since you wouldn't mind
doing this Roman we've talked about this
factor doesn't need to deal with this
kind of thing listen I know you think
that giving her an easy life is what's
best oh it's really not yes it's gonna
[ __ ] things up this is far from an easy
life Roman you know what I mean she
needs to know the sacrifices we have to
make to survive in this world as long as
she knows how to protect herself it's
fine
I don't want her to stop caring about
people okay
what's that woody
no no I'll check it out no back out
front looking forward to that suit I
don't like where this is going birch ah
yes
how you doing what's up he sounds I
wonder who does the voice acting for
that I'm not home alright let's check
this one out
oh go ahead what is she eating it's a
bunny
what was it
what is that is that a dog oh so it's
it's it's a buddy here but happening
here buddy buddy buddy here buddy buddy
I'm going this way I'm going this way
so she found a little puppy that a
you're not comprendo
okay well I guess we'd go back in then
why do they need food Wow Jesus don't
ever [ __ ] do that again
whoa what's your problem I do this all
the time you don't get all pissed off
it's not safe you just you can't go
jumping out at people not anymore
it's not safe but what if I had a weapon
I could have thought you were a walker
are you talking about Hey look I she
doesn't know about Walker's walkers out
back eating a puppy I wasn't a puppy
yeah I guess it just got to me you know
it was it was so little
you don't think about babies anymore but
after a while you just kind of accept
this is it
yeah that is [ __ ] up kind of forget
poor papi right but then you know
there it is you see it and you want to
protect it and
under the sex
maybe if Clive dies next we can put him
out there instead he'd make a better
watchdog anyway
Wow really Becca Becca don't make me
find out Becca
something's going on outside yeah is it
there eating no no something bad
we gotta find Roman so you sorry has
something to do with the [ __ ] diner
come here everyone [ __ ] come on we gotta
find Roman who this man if so can't be
bad she's what what is going on here my
god not what did you do
all I did was put on the blindfold and
bind his wrists somebody else beat him
up you already had the cuts and bruises
watchdog's caught him trying to steal
supplies is he bitten no they didn't get
that close well who is he who is he
I got no idea I don't think he speaks
English I can't believe he just snuck a
second break-in we've had in the last
couple of weeks last time we couldn't
catch him they got away with more
medicine than we could afford to lose we
all know what it's like trying to
survive out there he just came in here
for food that's just giving some huh
send him on his way tell more he could
have been out yeah I don't like that
lady right he could be part of a larger
because there were more I think we would
have seen no she never asked I mean
nobody travels alone by choice anymore
right Boyd's right we should just let
him go
why look at the poor bastard we've all
done the same thing trying to survive
well they don't have to be responsible
for him
but we can give him some food and let
him take his own John about his chances
it's about hours well what's to stop her
from coming back and armed next time we
could always use more hands keeping the
place securing we don't need any more
people here and look at him
who's he can't even speak English this
group works because we know how to
communicate we cook the old lady I need
her
I'm not gonna drop the racist bomb on
her that's that's racist judging him
based on race course not
yes you are come home well he's not
staying here but come on a stranger and
everything starts breaking down the last
time we did that we lost breathe and
then Vernon with that grin Vernon Vernon
and the boat are the reason that Ruth
fell apart not trusting strangers
he made us beat up that guy with the
mustache and steal his boat we did that
I've regretted it ever since that's when
our group fell apart he can't stay here
I agree keeping him here oh I think they
are in his condition
you'd be a drain on our resources no way
look we all know what we're talking
about here so let's stop dancing around
it
we either let this guy go and take our
Oasis or we kill him
are you serious
please are you serious Romans right it's
got to be one or the other
we are letting him go it's the only
right thing to do I'm telling you we
can't do that but killing him is that
really the answer
Stephanie bored you too don't think we
should kill him we know where joy seek
live stand on the subject what about us
what about meal what about the bro Z I
don't know
set him free we have to set him free
after me he's not even armed we can't
just kill him
this isn't in self-defense isn't it
though if it means you can't come back
to hurt us that isn't the same thing but
I had a choice that was a long time ago
and you stole the boat you [ __ ] this
man and we're giving up a part of
ourselves that we can never get back I'm
not ready to let that go I don't like
her she's racist she's damn racist cut
him free I hope you guys know what
you're doing I think we did the right
choice here are some food
Freddy share more cake just as a gesture
of good faith
get him out of here
I don't know if you can understand a
word I'm saying but you better
understand this you came this close to
death today and if you ever ever come
near this place again or tell anybody
where we are you wish you had died today
but a ball nice little bonding moments
right there
come here you okay I think this was my
least favorite out of all of them oh
it's not over good good cuz that was
kind of lame do you have any fours nope
do you have any sevens
uh nope he'll fish hey I miss playing
guitar for everyone me it was stupid but
fun why don't we do that anymore cuz you
have my back there's a lot we don't do
anymore I shouldn't have let that guy go
really it'd still be alive and
everything would be the same I'd agreed
it was the right thing to do
anyway Romans obsessed with keeping this
place secured now you know that's
impossible right
why well after last time Roman hasn't
taken any chances Reni should fix the
loose board behind the storage lots
Becca are you sneaking out again do you
know how dangerous that is know how
dangerous that is
it's not dangerous there's nothing out
there but slow-ass why are you talking
about we've had two break-ins already
anyone could be out there what if
someone sees you and follows you back
here
they won't how can they not find a diner
anyway she'll I need to talk to you it's
open I don't understand this what's
going on oh he teleports cool
hey Becca Hey when you get a sec I need
you to come out and talk to me it's
important okay what can be somebody
outside you'll see me well okay good
just give us why can't we talk in here
we can talk here
no just finish up here come find me
don't take too long what was that all
about
don't worry about probably nothing
probably know that at el Mar you said it
was important
yeah well these days everything's
important to Roman stay here it'll be
just a minute I'll fill you in when I
get back
okay I feel like every story [ __ ] has
hit the fan at one point but in this one
[ __ ] has not hit the fame the [ __ ] is
still in the toilet which is kind of
weird look I can look at plants so
that's game no one's watering these I
don't know it's beautiful don't be so
depressed you were playing cards
alright Joyce no no no not that [ __ ] oh
geez I guess we got to talk to her son
of a [ __ ]
all right Joyce so Joyce is I think they
are the cancer patients that was from
episode 4 that stole the boat you bros
remember that you know what's going on I
don't know if I should say anything why
he's what is it someone got Betty cops
Stefan is stealing and then trying to
escape Oh God
what are they gonna do I don't know what
can we do
who was Stephanie out to Roman oh it was
their friend here now
uh-oh okay well we're gonna have to kill
her
it's not my fault she [ __ ] up Roman
good your dad demon eyes I heard about
Stephanie
oh I'm sorry what are you gonna do yeah
what are you gonna do what happened
we caught her trying to escape so what
so what Roman ever since the incident
this hasn't been an easy place to live
in if she doesn't want to stay let her
take her chances out there
well a she had most of our seeds
medicine and hammer with her and B you
know we can't let anyone leave who knows
where we are
come on Michelle all of us now we're in
that position again where we can't keep
her here and we can't let her go you do
know why I'm telling you this right
you want to meet it no [ __ ] die duck
doesn't matter it matters to me
you and Boyd we're gonna kill her she's
a friend convinced us all to take that
chance but we did it was wrong and now
Boyd is dead we're beyond the luxury of
taking chances now and I need to know
that you're with us a hundred percent
I'm not let's talk to our favor first
see if we can talk some sense into her
no she tried to sneak out and leave us
without any medicine or extra ammo she
knew that could mean the death of any
one of us that isn't a second chance she
might not try to leave so quietly you
got your gun it's in the camper I'll
give you a few minutes to get your head
together
no [ __ ] way God what do I tell Becca
that's up to you whatever you say I'll
back you up that is [ __ ] up what kind
of world is worth living if that's the
case you know she'll what's wrong No
am I in trouble no you're not
it's gonna be hard for you what I'm
gonna say it's gonna be hard to hear
what is it it's Stephanie
she stole a bunch of AnnaLynne medicine
and tried to escape oh my god the hell
did she do that for Roman says we have
to kill her
yeah why would she do this to us
wow she really didn't argue on that one
well this place isn't that safe because
this place isn't safe anymore after
those guys attacked us
even after we let their friend go this
place just hasn't been the same course
not Romans trying to make it better
better no it's happy anymore yeah like
prisoners but it's safe here I mean yeah
I want to get away every now and then
but I would never leave that's crazy
is it Roman wants me to do it is it I'm
sorry I want to get it over with
no guns over there in the drawer this is
when the [ __ ] hits the fan huh
where is his when the [ __ ] goes in and
it just goes everywhere and everyone's
face and you first try to lick it and
see what it is and then you realize what
it is and then you're like oh I don't
want this to be who we are just let me
do it then what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you no I'll do it you [ __ ] you shouldn't
ever have to do something like this I
just need a second this really sucks
yeah it does I care you know we don't
have to do this we can just go yeah what
we've survived on our own before if we
just go we can be out of here before
anyone can do anything about it
are you crazy where would we go there's
nothing out there as long as we're here
we're safe
the group will protect us but for how
long
yeah I don't know longer than we'd
survive out there besides you know the
rules if we try to leave Roman will hunt
us down we don't have a choice
this is who we are now no it's not shel
it's time
[ __ ] this is dumb this is dumb no I am I
am driving away I'm not killing my doing
she'll jump what the hell sit down get
safe
whoa
I don't know what do you Bruce think let
me know I just killing your friend know
that is [ __ ] up
why would we do that honestly I mean we
didn't [ __ ] kill the other guy why
would we kill our [ __ ] friend that
doesn't make any sense whatsoever I
think they wanted you to kill uh the
first guy and then we conflicted about
the other one cuz this is no that didn't
make any sense anyway hope it wasn't
your watching we only do the last one
next one time hit subscriber come abroad
today and I'll see in the next one sale
somebody bar